We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P..
I have something special for you today.
My live stream viewers may already be familiar
with this.
We have a number of regular callers to the
show, many of whom have been calling in for
a long time.
You've got Troy Yawk, you've got the San Antonio
troll.
You've got the Kansas troll who hasn't called
in for a while.
We have our friend, the Egg Man.
He's a friendly, regular caller.
There's all these regular callers.
We have a new caller who we are calling repeater,
like Peter, the name Peter Re hyphen Peter
because he will just call and call and call,
repeating the exact same things over and over
again.
I introduced him to the audience two weeks
ago on a live stream where he called me six
times in a row with the same message last
week.
He called me fifteen times in a row with the
same message.
I don't want to deprive the TV and podcast
audience from this, so I've received ten more
voicemails.
Just take a listen to this, OK?
I'm just going to give you a sampling.
Each voicemail is two to three minutes long.
We'll just listen to a few seconds.
Here's the first one.
David, the gossip show I'm calling about,
you're talking about this virus.
Listen to me very carefully.
You're not going to understand this because,
you know, you're just not that smart.
Ninety nine percent of the people who get
the virus survive the virus.
You only have only one percent out of the
people that get the virus passed from it.
OK, so that's voicemail number one, then,
number two.
David, the gossip show, listen to me very
carefully, this is about the Cauvin.
Ninety nine percent of the people who get
it survive it.
That means you only have one percent of people
that get it that don't survive it.
Ninety nine percent, ninety nine percent,
so that goes on for two minutes, then another
voice mail coming in.
Oops, sorry.
Here we go.
I'm going to repeat myself again, David.
The glass itself.
And like I said, David, you act like a little
girl.
You belong in a dress and then put some lipstick
on it.
High heels.
The coronavirus is actually from China.
It's actually the China virus.
That's where the word came from anyways.
Ninety nine percent of the people who get
the coronavirus.
So that went on for three minutes, which is
the maximum that our system allows.
Call number four.
This is for David, the gossip show about the
coronavirus, 99 percent of the people who
get the virus survives the virus.
That was two more minutes.
Here's a voicemail, number five.
I'll say it one more time, David, about the
coronavirus, 99 percent of the people who
get the coronavirus, they survive the coronavirus.
That means just a little over one percent
of the people who get it don't survive the
virus.
Voicemail number six davit the gossip show.
So this is real simple.
We have forensic proof that these Dominion
machines.
Oh, boy.
Do certain things to flip votes.
So now he switches the Dominion voicemail.
Number seven, these Dominion machines, we
have forensic evidence, evidence numbers which
don't lie.
And then voicemail number eight, it's real
simple.
These Dominion machines are designed for fraud.
OK, and then so there's five more.
Can isn't it insane that this is like part
of my job, that I don't know what to tell
you, my friends?
I don't know what to tell you, but that the
world is in rough shape.
I think that any anything more specific as
a commentary about this would really not do
a justice.
The world is in rough shape.
We've got a great bonus show for you.
We will talk about the new U.K. strain of
the coronavirus and its implications.
We will talk about a lot of other things.
Make sure you are a member and you will get
instant access to the bonus show.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com coupon code
always available.
Fresh start to save a bundle off of the membership
of your choice.